the movie begins at a police station in
Shanghai where the boss of a local gang
violently assaults a police officer who
seems to have arrested his girlfriend
the other officers present at the
station only watch in horror as they are
scared to death of the mighty crocodile
gang after they finish off the poor cop
the gang exits the police station only
to realize that their vehicles have been
stolen just then a formidable rival
group known as the ax gang shows up with
over 500 members they are wearing
professional suits as if they are going
to attend a business meeting scared the
crocodile gang attempts to retreat back
into the police station but the officers
close the door leaving them trapped
desperate for assistance one of the gang
members fires a signal into the sky as a
call for backup however they receive a
distressing response from the leader of
the ax gang named brother some who
reveals that their remaining members
have already joined forces with them the
ax gang then opens fire quickly killing
most of the crocodile members seeing
this their boss tries to escape but one
of of the rivals hurls and acts at him
severing his leg from his body brother
some then proceeds to taunt him with
dance-like movements before fatally
stabbing him this terrifying turn of
events causes panic in the boss's
girlfriend who pleads for her life but
brother some cruelly shoots her as well
it is the year 1940 a period
characterized by social unrest and Chaos
where different gangs compete for power
among these factions the ax gang emerges
as the most feared deriving its name
from its preferred weapon only the
inhabitants of the poorest districts who
have no interest in the gang conflicts
are able to live in relative peace one
such place is pig Stylee a tenement
housing a diverse group of people with
various occupations overseen by a
lecherous landlord and his domineering
wife the landlord often drunk instills
fear in the residence through his
inappropriate insults and taunts the
only one who can control him is his
always angry wife who frequently yells
at the tenants to pay their rent one day
two troublemakers named Singh bone
arrive at pigsty alley pretending to be
members of the ax gang in order to earn
respect they approached the local barber
and Bone Gets a Haircut however when the
service is completed the duo refuses to
pay asserting their affiliation with the
ax gang unfazed the barber stands his
crowd and insists on receiving payment
he gathers the other residents of the
alley but Singh pretends to be unafraid
and even adopts a fighting stance he
then challenges a woman to step forward
and strike him as hard as she can the
woman obliges and lands a powerful blow
on Singh's abdomen which hurts him more
than he had expected realizing he cannot
defeat her Singh quickly changes his
opponent and invites an old man who is
peeking through the crowd to his dismay
the man turns out to be fully ripped so
Singh once again changes his opponent
then invites a six-year-old boy to step
forward unfortunately even this boy is
dieseld beyond belief the commotion
eventually attracts the attention of the
landlady who arrives at the scene and
immediately strikes Singh with her
sandal in retaliation he threatens to
summon backup and throws a firecracker
over the wall coincidentally it hits a
real member of the ax gang who just
happens to be nearby in the next scene
the gang members enter the alley
inquiring about the person responsible
for the firecracker Singh points towards
the landlady causing her to run away in
fear just then the barber steps forward
and fearlessly claims that he is not
intimidated one of the gang members
approaches him with an ax but the barber
delivers a powerful blow throwing him
into a barrel this action prompts the
other gang members to summon their
entire force of the ax gang minutes
later the Army led by Brother some
arrives at pigsty alley brother some
demands to know the identity of the
person who provoked the ax gang when no
one steps forward he takes a mother and
her son hostage threatening to burn them
alive as a result of seemingly ordinary
guy named Cooley steps forward the gang
wastes no time in attacking him but to
their surprise Cooley reveals himself as
a skilled kung fu fighter effortlessly
defeating the gang members with his
remarkable fighting abilities when he
finally starts getting overwhelmed two
other Kung food Masters named Taylor and
donut join him together the trio
overpowers the entire ax gang forcing
them to retreat in the aftermath brother
some hold sing and Bone captive
intending to execute them for all the
trouble they cost however when a gang
member throws an ax at them Singh
demonstrates his lock picking skills and
manages to free himself as well as his
friend in the neck of time impressed by
his resourcefulness brother some offers
them a chance to join the gang on the
condition that they murder someone later
on the street Singh reveals his
childhood to Bone recalling an incident
when he was deceived by a beggar into
purchasing a martial arts pamphlet with
all of his savings after diligently
practicing the techniques outlined in
the pamphlet Singh attempted to rescue a
mute girl named Fong from bullies but
ended up being beaten and humiliated
since then Singh became adamant that
Heroes never win and resolved to embrace
a villainous pass returning to the
present he and Bone discussed their
potential Target for the assassination
mission but before embarking on their
deadly task they steal ice cream from
poor street vendor free ice cream is the
best reason to become a bad guy back at
pigsty alley the landlady decides to
evict the three Kung Fu Masters claiming
them to be responsible for the recent
chaos however the other tenants oppose
her choice considering the Masters as
their saviors as the dispute escalates
sing and Bone arrive at pigsty alley
with the intention of killing the
landlady and seeking Vengeance they lurk
in a corner and try assassinating her
secretly but their efforts go horribly
wrong when Singh tries throwing a knife
it ricochets off a wall and stabs him in
the shoulder bones aim is even worse as
no matter how hard he tries he only ends
up stabbing his friend's other shoulder
to worsen matters the landlady notices
their presence and gives them chase bone
tries to scare her off by grabbing a
large box but unfortunately it contains
several venomous snakes which break out
of the box and bite sing left with no
options the two friends quickly separate
and the landlady decides to go after
sing but in the process she gets into an
accident allowing the guys to escape
following this Singh takes refuge in a
draft Pulpit where his body miraculously
heals in a matter of seconds once fully
healed he reunites with bone but is
unable to explain the strange events
elsewhere brother some seeking revenge
against the residents of pigsty alley
recruits to harpists a skilled Duo of
Assassins who use a magical gookin as
their weapon they strike Pig Stylee at
night and easily take out Cooley when he
is distracted as the Assassins turn
their attention to Taylor and donut they
unleash invisible weapons through their
gookin the two Kung Fu Masters initially
managed to defend themselves but are
ultimately overwhelmed by the superior
skills of the harpists just as the
Assassins are about to deliver the final
blow the landlord and the landlady
intervene revealing their own Mastery of
kung fu the landlord utilizes his
agility to evade attacks and counter
with Deft strikes while the landlady
finishes off the harpists with her
powerful lion's roar technique after the
intense battle the couple enters
brother's son's car warning him to stay
away from Pig's Stylee in the aftermath
of the Dreadful battle the 10 evidence
of pig's dially gather around the
injured kung fu fighters sharing their
sorrow and concern they question why the
landlord and landlady did not intervene
earlier to save them in response the
landlady reveals that despite their
formidable kung fu skills they
tragically lost their son as a result of
seeking Revenge since that heartbreaking
incident they made a vow to abstain from
further violence the following day sing
and Bone are on a bus where they are
subjected to humiliation and physical
assaults even by a simple clerk fueled
by anger Singh decides to take out his
rage on the same ice cream vendor from
before he holds her at knife Point
demanding money but she remains unafraid
she tries to communicate with Singh
through sign language leading him to
realize that she's the same mute girl
from his childhood whom he had tried to
protect from bullies Singh recognizes
the old lollipop she offers him as a
token of gratitude but in shame he
smashes it into Parts overwhelmed Singh
pushes bone away warning him to not
follow him any longer later Singh is
sitting alone on a sidewalk he is sudden
apprehended by members of the ax gang
and brought before brother some
surprisingly the leader allows Singh to
become a member of the gang which fills
him with happiness however he has soon
assigned a mission to infiltrate a
mental Asylum and release the beast a
mercenary rumored to be the most
dangerous person alive Singh agrees and
quickly gets to work that night he
covertly sneaks into the Asylum and uses
his lock picking skills to free the
Beast Singh then escorts him to the
gang's Hideout located behind a casino
brother some is initially skeptical due
to the beast's flippant attitude and
sloppy appearance however they are
ultimately convinced when the most
dangerous men in the world fires a gun
Point Blank at his own head then stops
the bullet with just two fingers all the
members of the ax gang bowed down in
respect and brother some asks the Beast
whatever he desires to work for them but
the man only says I want a worthy
opponent the Beast that unleashes a
deadly kick which breaks the wall and
makes way to the nearby casino where the
landlord and landlady are currently at
least sitting following this the three
skilled Kung Fu Masters engage in a
Fierce and intense fight showcasing
their exceptional abilities but as the
battle wears on it becomes evident that
the couple is no match against the Beast
the landlady performs her powerful Lions
Roar technique but it proves ineffective
fortunately they have brought along a
massive funeral Bell while the landlord
confronts the beast in combat the
landlady severs the top part of the Bell
transforming it into a makeshift
megaphone she then harnesses its
amplification properties to enhance her
lion's roar finally subduing her
opponent injured the Beast attempts to
surrender but at an opportune moment he
stabs the couple with poisoned darts in
response the landlord and landlady
counter the beast's attack and the three
end up in a stalemate witnessing all of
this brother some orders sing to
eliminate the couple however with a
newfound sense of redemption Singh
strikes the Beast forcefully on the head
instead enraged the Beast breaks free
from The Joint lock and pummels sing
through a hole this gives the landlord
landlady a short window of opportunity
so they quickly grabbed the unconscious
sing and make their escape enraged
brother some orders the Beast to go
after them but the latter ends up
killing him with a single punch back at
Pig Stylee the landlord and landlady rap
sing from head to toe in bandages and
administer traditional Chinese medicine
to him to their surprise he undergoes a
transformative metamorphosis displaying
an astonishingly quick recovery
witnessing this miraculous change the
landlady deduces that Singh is in fact a
one in a million Natural Born Kung Fu
Master it is then revealed that the
brutal assault by the Beast earlier had
unlocked sings chi flow unleashing his
true potential as a great Kung Fu Master
meanwhile the ax gang along with the
Beast makes their way to Pig Stylee
fully prepared to cause destruction the
gangsters launched their attacks on sing
but he effortlessly repels them with his
profound power he takes down numerous
gang members at once tossing them into
the air like ragdolls eventually sin
confronts the Beast leading to a final
an epic battle between the two masters
Singh initially gains the upper hand
overpowering the Beast with ease however
the Beast performs his ultimate toad
technique
regaining the advantages he forcefully
headbutts sing through walls in a
powerful move the Beast then throws
Singh High into the sky sending him
soaring for hundreds of miles at this
moment it appears as if our protagonist
is going to be defeated but just then a
colossal Buddha figure emerges from the
clouds and offers His blessings this
gives Singh renewed hope and he launches
back to Earth during his descent his
palms ignite into flames unleashing his
long-lost buddha palm technique that
flattens his opponent seemingly defeated
the Beast feigns surrender causing Singh
to lower his guard however just like the
previous instance he attempts to strike
Singh with his poisoned Barb fortunately
our hero is well prepared and he
delivers another powerful blow creating
a palm-shaped hole in the tenement's
wall this finally subdues the Beast
causing him to kneel down and surrender
before the mighty sing in the final
scene sing and Bone open a candy store
with Fong's lollipop as their logo as
the mute ice cream vendor passes by
Singh steps out to greet her in a
heartwarming moment they recognize each
other and joyfully run into the shop the
scene also showcases the residents of
pig's dially including the landlord and
landlady living their lives as ordinary
citizens the movie ends as the beggar
from earlier offers a collection of
martial arts manuals to a young boy who
is enjoying a lollipop
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching